[Musique]
étrangère
intimidée
[Musique]
c'est assez impressionnant
et bien maintenant ils éteignent la lumière mais dans
la série tu verras à quel point
la vie a été impressionnante
pour moi leur relation est l'élément le plus
important de cette série  et c'est
une représentation très puissante du mariage
car ils sont passés de deux
jeunes qui ne pouvaient pas se parler
à être les plus grands alliés l'un de l'autre.
[Musique] [
Musique]
finalement Louis XVI est son ami mais
pour commencer il est elle  premier ennemi je ne
ressens
rien
Marie Antoinette est vite très
déçue par son mari Louis était
très timide et ne lui a pas parlé pendant
presque trois trois épisodes
ce qui m'a surpris chez Louis c'est la
transformation qu'il subit donc quand
on rencontre Louis pour la première fois, c'est un  enfant,
nous
vivons toujours dans un monde de sa Terre.
Louis était connu pour être un grand amoureux de la nature, il
aime ses chevaux et adore chasser,
il est très très calme et il a très
peur,
la seule situation dans l'établissement
[Musique]
est
trop difficile pour que vous l'admettiez  mon père
avait tort à mon sujet
tu sais qu'il avait raison
frère
il n'a jamais vraiment été censé être roi
son frère aîné était censé être Ken
appelé la provence qui est mon frère il
est tout ce que Louis devrait être il est
le plus beau frère il est le
frère plus fort, il parle Louis ne
parle pas, euh, il est tout ce qu'un bon roi
serait, euh
et il veut vraiment être le roi
aussi, il est jaloux de la position de Louie,
tu sais, je ne devrais pas perdre un instant
à livrer là-bas
[La musique]
serait probablement bien meilleure  pour tout le monde s'ils viennent
de changer mais ce n'est pas comme ça que
l'histoire se passe donc il est dans une
situation où il n'est prêt à
rien je ne suis pas prêt à être père
et bien je pense que c'est là que l'on voit le
changement d'un jeune garçon  et une jeune fille
ne voulant pas avoir grand-chose à voir les uns avec les
autres et Louis refusant de faire son
devoir qu'il était tenu de faire, c'est-à-dire
consommer son mariage parce que
plus que quiconque à Versailles, il était
mécontent
d'être marié, il n'avait que 15 ans et un
à moitié et il ne voulait pas se marier
et à sa manière il était tout aussi
rebelle qu'elle l'était
tu sais que leur mariage démarre très très très très
lentement ne peut pas tenir
éternellement n'est-ce pas,
ça fait quatre  mois, le gros problème
des sept huit premières années de cette
relation, ce sont les relations sexuelles
qui étaient inexistantes. Quand
vas-tu déboutonner tes brèches et baiser
ta femme,
il y a beaucoup de théories à ce sujet et
sur pourquoi ils n'ont pas eu de relations sexuelles pendant  Au cours des
huit premières années de leur mariage, certaines
personnes pensent que c'était des problèmes médicaux,
certaines personnes pensent que ce n'était tout simplement pas une
attirance pour
mon petit-fils. Après avoir fait des
recherches et après y avoir beaucoup réfléchi,
je pense que c'est juste un jeune de 15 ans.
garçon qui est terrifié, le sexe dans leur cas
n'avait rien d'
amusant c'était le devoir c'était le devoir c'était
lié à tellement de tension et
de pression alors bien sûr ils se sont enfuis
il
a une salle pleine de gens quand ils se
marient qui regardent c'est normal
que  ils ne veulent pas avoir de relations sexuelles, je pense
qu'il associe le sexe à tu sais, la terreur,
vraiment,
tu sais, personne ne leur a parlé d'être
intimes l'un avec l'autre, ils ne connaissaient pas les
insectes, c'est vrai,
non,
je ne pense pas
[Musique]
les deux  Parmi eux, ils se sont fait des amis à
un moment donné, mais il leur a été très très
difficile de
créer un mariage normal et sain.
Je pense qu'elle n'est pas adaptée à la vie à
Versailles.
Louis est ce personnage né dans une
société où les hommes obtiendront simplement ce qu'ils veulent.
veux et surtout un roi il a
été élevé pour avoir l'idée que
tout ce qu'il veut lui va et une femme est
là pour le soutenir Deborah montre ce
côté de Louis qui est complètement
une incompréhension des femmes il ne comprend pas
l'importance qu'elles jouent l'
intelligence et la Vibrance imaginaire
apporte à cet accord et comment c'est elle
qui le change de l'intérieur
pour la meilleure
[Musique] étrangère qu'ils
ont, vous savez, s'est un peu
rapprochée, je pense qu'au tout début,
c'est vraiment une question de contact physique donc
trois en fait là où elle est  apprenant à
se lever et Louis arrive et ajuste
son siège et c'est ce tout petit
moment mais cet éclair d'électricité
les traverse c'est le premier moment où
ils ont un contact approprié qu'ils
contrôlent, ils n'ont pas été forcés
ensemble pour leur mariage, ils  je n'y
suis pas allée tu sais c'est eux et c'est
ces deux personnes passer un moment ensemble
étrangère
meurt
elle se sent triste elle sait combien Louis
XV comptait pour son mari Louis XVI mais
elle est aussi terrifiée car ça veut dire
qu'elle sera reine de France mais
heureusement,
elle peut entrer dans ce nouveau chapitre de sa
vie avec un sentiment d'unité avec
son mari Louie je ne fais pas ça
nous le ferons ensemble dans l'épisode 6
Frère Joseph arrive et nous propose
une sorte de séance de conseil matrimonial une
prostituée pourquoi pas  le mari ne
s'égare pas s'il aime sa femme et tout à coup
il admet qu'il aime vraiment sa
femme et je pense qu'elle ne s'en rend pas vraiment
compte parce qu'il ne l'a pas exprimé
alors tu m'aimes
mais tout au long de la série il y a
beaucoup d'armes, des hauts et des bas dans cette
saison entre cela,
il leur faut sept ans pour créer une
fin mai dans chaque ville ce soir
et à la fin bien que leur mariage
ne soit pas consommé, il accepte qu'elle est
son amie et qu'ils doivent forger une
alliance  ensemble pour s'en sortir
parce que c'est tout simplement trop pour
eux deux et c'est à ce moment-là qu'ils cimentent leur
amitié et je pense que cela les aide à se retrouver,
il devient ce
personnage intellectuel vif, rapide et fort à la fin quand il est
le roi
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
il ne voulait pas partir
et elle a toujours été là pour lui
jusqu'à la fin
elle aurait pu s'échapper mais elle a choisi de ne pas le faire
[Musique]